qu'arthur bataille j'ai 32 ans et je
suis dirigeant de sidi comme et de sylla
si la société de cyber entraînements et
partenaires de l'école de 2600
silas est une solution de cyber
entraînement qui permet de former des
ingénieurs des administrateurs systèmes
réseau des développeurs aux enjeux de la
sécurité des systèmes d'information axel
dreyfus 30 depuis 20 ans je suis le co
fondateur de l'école de 1600 une école
spécialisée en cybersécurité en
alternance
[Musique]
nous avons un tiers de la formation qui
est dispensée à partir de cours
magistraux et de peer-to-peer learning à
travers notre promotion de 60 élèves et
le reste du temps les étudiants sont en
alternance dans les entreprises pour se
spécialiser dans les métiers de figure
c'est déjà un partenariat d'intérêt
c'est une vision commune de ce que doit
être la formation dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité nous avons des échanges à
travers
si la silicone sur l'écosystème et sur
le besoin des entreprises
c'est également aussi une belle
opportunité pour nous d'avoir des
alternants puisqu'on a la foi d
alternance soit société silicon mais sur
la société si là pour créer des contenus
et des attaques sur notre notre petite
formation lors des échanges réguliers
par rapport au corpus de cours par
rapport aussi la plus pédagogique
on a effectivement un échange
excessivement riche pour correspondre
aux besoins des entreprises c'est
également aussi un lieu pour la
formation leur skilling notamment des
demandeurs d'emploi et donc de pouvoir
les amener vers les métiers de la
cybersécurité ce qui a aussi un fort
intérêt pour le compte de silicone
bénéficie d'expérience arthur et ses
équipes aujourd'hui sur l'élaboration du
syllabus évident on remonte auprès
d'arthur aussi tout et perception qu'on
peut avoir encore de signaux faibles par
rapport aux besoins du marché
c'était une mutualisation de moyens et
en termes la fera évidemment on a aussi
des échanges croisés aujourd'hui sur les
formations et personnes qui sont formés
aujourd'hui par part si l'école mais
s'ils assurent leur cyber aujourd'hui
sont souvent kurtag deux élèves ça nous
permet de cohabiter avec ces jeunes qui
sont les futurs la cybersécurité de
demain ne les avoir à la fois pour nous
en tant que alternant mais également en
tant que futur potentiel d'utilisateurs
et peut-être même employés des deux
solutions que sont cyniques investi là
[Musique]